-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we're gonna get
to the news.
President Biden is facing
criticism after he fist-bumped
Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman
last week during their
first in-person meeting.
Of course, at this point,
that's like saying
"Mosquitos are
facing criticism."
When weren't they?
[ Light laughter ]
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
apologized last week,
after she said that
the Latino community is, quote,
"as unique as the breakfast
tacos here in San Antonio."
[ Laughter ]
Said Biden in her apology,
"I'm as sorry
as the breakfast tacos
at Taco Bell."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump and
former Vice President
Mike Pence are set to hold
competing rallies on Friday
in Arizona.
It will be the first time
they've faced off
since January 6th.
[ Audience ohs ]
Jennifer Lopez and Ben Affleck
over the weekend
reportedly got married.
Guests were offered beef,
chicken,
or bacon, egg, and cheese.
[ Light laughter ]
I felt really good
about that joke earlier.
[ Laughter ]
You know what,
it's for a certain --
it's for a certain region
of America.
[ Light laughter ]
Hope you enjoy it, New England!
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Ben Affleck
and Jennifer Lopez
reportedly got married over
the weekend, because right now,
that's the only way a Red Sox
fan can get a win in the Bronx.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Audience oohs ]
Wow. I took it right --
I took it right back.
Told a joke for New England
that bombed in New York,
And then [bleep] 'em
with the next joke.
[ Laughter ]
Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
announced recently
that the coffee chain will close
16 stores due to rising crime.
The most egregious crime?
Waiting until you're
at the front of the line
before looking at the menu.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, so the sizes
are in Italian."
[ Laughter ]
The fast food restaurant Subway
recently changed the names
of several of its sandwiches,
including switching
the meatball marinara
to "The Boss,"
as opposed to what's usually
called "the boss" at Subway --
a 16-year-old kid.
[ Laughter ]
Lego recently announced
that they will release
a new set based on the sitcom
"The Office."
Though, if your kid wants that,
bad news, they're a Dwight.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, producers have
announced that a reboot
of the procedural
"Criminal Minds" will air
on the streaming service
Paramount+.
So if you're a big fan of
detective work,
try and figure out how to watch
Paramount+.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Peacock made me tell
that last joke.